bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien bienvenue dans cette deuxième vidéo
consacrée au travail de paul lazarsfeld
et aux modèles de columbia sur la
sociologie du vote pour rappel dans le
dernier épisode on avait détaillé un
petit peu la vie et les méthodes de paul
lazarsfeld qui avait montré dans son
livre the people's choice que le vote
est principalement déterminé parce qu'on
avait appelé les variables lourde du
vote qui sont notamment le revenu le
lieu d'habitation et surtout la religion
mais une autre question qui s'était posé
en commençant son étude 1 c'était de
savoir dans quelle mesure la campagne
médiatique avait pu convaincre les
électeurs de voter pour tel ou tel
candidat c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qu'on commente encore beaucoup
aujourd'hui on l'a vu dernièrement
machin fait une bonne campagne truc
s'est trompé de stratégie il ou elle
s'est vautré pendant le débat du second
tour bref on commente énormément toutes
ces petites stratégies de campagne en
partant du principe que ça a un effet
déterminant sur les résultats du vote
mais est ce qu'on est vraiment sûr de ça
bref la question c'est de savoir est-ce
qu'on ait ou non influencés par les
médias c'est ce qu'on va voir génériques
et on serait pas un bol de céréales en
attendant là
[Musique]
alors je suis déjà revenu vite fait sur
la vie de paul lazarsfeld dans l'épisode
un mathématicien autrichien brillant et
ont obtenu son doctorat seulement 22 ans
il abandonne viennent pour partir aux
etats-unis notamment parce que les
américains lui permettent de fonder un
laboratoire d'analysé sociale et aussi
sûrement parce qu'ils étaient juifs en
autriche dans les années 30 ça a dû
jouer aussi mais ce que je n'avais pas
dit c'est que lors de sa jeunesse
viennoise militante il va côtoyer des
joyeux lurons membre de l'institute for
socialiste wang qing solution social'
bien sûr prochain il s'est tu fu social
forschung social fourchaume social
forschung il va côtoyer l'institute for
social forschung un mot d'allemand est
toujours aussi divin c'est ça ne vous
dit rien c'est normal parce que c'est
cet institut qui va devenir plus tard la
fameuse école de francfort avec des
personnalités comme horkheimer et adorno
ou herbert marcuse alors si ces gens ne
vous disent absolument rien et que vous
ne savez pas si l'école de francfort d
une plutôt en groupe d'intellectuels
marxiste ou un ca pesos si ces métiers
du port c'est pas grave il ya plein de
vidéos en parle notamment celles ci de
dedic tôt que je vous recommande vous
pouvez simplement avoir en tête que les
intellectuels de l'école de francfort
ils sont très critiques des médias de
masse qu'il voit vraiment comme une
aliénation complète des populations
alors les théoriciens de l'école de
francfort sont ceux qui réfléchissent le
plus tôt à l'effet aliénant des médias
de masse qui commence tout juste à
émerger un et ils sont particulièrement
inquiets face au développement de la
propagande politique encore une fois on
est en allemagne dans les années 20 30
donc en terme de propagande politique
effectivement il ya de quoi faire alors
le procédé existe depuis longtemps mais
les années 30 c'est un moment où les
états fascistes comprennent l'importance
du médium vidéo pour asseoir leur
idéologie dès septembre 1933 le parti
nazi créer un département du film au
sein du bureau central de la propagande
dirigée par joseph goebbels cela
aboutira notamment au fameux triomphe de
la volonté 1 le film de la réalisatrice
leni riefenstahl qui présente hitler
comme un véritable dieu vivant et qui a
façonné une bonne partie de l'imagerie
nazis telle qu'on la connaît le fasciste
italien ne sont pas en reste 1 dès 1937
mousseline y construira sa fameuse
cinecitta un énorme complexe
cinématographique pensé dès le début
comme une arme de la propagande fasciste
dans ce contexte on comprend que les
intellectuels de l'école de francfort
soit extrêmement critique à l'égard des
nouveaux médias et il théorise donc
l'existence en fait de médias qui serait
omnipotent capable de manipuler
complètement les foules qui elles
seraient vus comme des espèces de
moutons complètement passif ce qui est
peut être un peu exagéré tu imagines tu
remonte dans le temps pour leur montrer
les smartphones d'aujourd'hui légal très
bons retours et rien fait du tout parce
que c'était des intellectuels en cravate
mais il aurait été déprimés de ouf du
coup il faut avoir en tête que dans les
années 40 le consensus semble plutôt que
les médias sont complètement
manipulateur qui manipulent les foules
et qui sont capables d'orienter les
comportements aussi bien les
comportements politiques 1 que les
comportements de consommation et c'est
précisément l'un des points que paul
lazarsfeld compte bien vérifier en
mettant en place l'an quête vers people
choice en 1940 bon en fait c'est surtout
dans le livre suivant voting de 1954
qu'ils vont préciser et confirmer les
résultats qui était encore un petit peu
embryonnaire dans la toute première
enquête
bon pour ne pas faire durer le suspense
trop longtemps lazarsfeld trouve que
contrairement aux thèses de l'école de
francfort la propagande médiatique n'a
pratiquement au churn impact sur les
choix électoraux c'est pas forcément
étonnant parce que pour rappel le
premier résultat que les a reçus elle
avait mis en avant c'est que les gens
ils étaient globalement très peu
intéressés par la campagne électorale
que doudou qu'on en avait plus ou moins
rien à rien répéter mais pour être plus
précis il ya quand même des gens qui
sont très intéressés par cette campagne
ça existe quand même ces boulimiques
d'informations qui vont tous lire tout
écouter tout décrypter mais justement
eux ce qu'ils lisent tout c'est
justement les gens qui sont très
politisés qui ont un avis tranché dès le
début de la campagne et du coup bah ils
ont pratiquement aucune chance de
changer d'avis al'inverse les personnes
peu politisées qui aurait des chances
d'être convaincu il est bon en général
c'est aussi celle qui en ont le moins
quelque chose à [ __ ] de la campagne et
des élections et qui du coup va suivre
absolument pas les débats et le
déroulement de la campagne médiatique du
coup on se retrouve dans cette espèce de
paradoxes où la propagande politique
touche presque exclusivement les
électeurs les moins disposés à changer
d'avis
et de fêtes l'enquète par panel a permis
de vérifier que seulement 8 % des
enquêtés avait véritablement changé
d'intentions de vote au cours des sept
mois de l' enquête pour rappel j'avais
expliqué dans l'épisode précédent ce qui
était une enquête par panel le disque on
a un groupe d'individus qu'on va
interroger plusieurs fois ce qui est
intéressant parce que justement ça
permet de voir les changements d'opinion
chez les mêmes personnes bon du coup
seulement 8 % du panel qui changent
d'avis ça fait vraiment pas beaucoup
mais bon la vraie question c'est pas
tant de savoir si c'est beaucoup ou pas
mais c'est surtout de savoir si on peut
conclure que la propagande électorale a
quand même réussi à faire changer d'avis
ces 8 % des lecteurs parce que si des
électeurs ont changé d'avis ça pourrait
être une preuve non négligeable que la
campagne a bien un effet sur les votes
même s'il est limité et bien là aussi il
va falloir regarder les données un peu
plus en détail lazarsfeld va bien
observer ces huit pour cent des gens à
qui on trouve effectivement modifié
leurs intentions de vote ces fameux par
le challenger à l'américaine et il
s'aperçoit que les deux tiers d'entre
eux en fait ne font que ce
aligné sur les intentions de leur groupe
primaire d'appartenance en gros c'est
des gens qui s'étaient écartés du vote
de leurs amis et de leur famille et qui
finalement se range à la norme dominante
dans leur milieu est ce qu'on s'aperçoit
c'est que ces reconversions s'explique
en général bien plus par des
conversations interpersonnelles avec
l'entourage que par l'effet de la con en
fait c'est même le grand résultat que va
mettre en avant la sarcelle sur la
formation des votes c'est que les
conversations avec l'entourage semble
bien plus déterminante pour façonner le
choix politique que la propagande
médiatique
alors ce résultat un qui montre
l'importance des conversations une
l'entourage il a été découvert
effectivement lors de la première
enquête de people choice de 1944 mais
presque par hasard et en fait c'était
loin d'être le coeur du livre pour être
tout à fait honnête il n'y avait qu'une
seule question sur le sujet et ont
demandé aux enquêtés s'il leur arrivait
ou non de donner des conseils de vote
donc c'était un peu léger pour tirer des
conclusions là dessus du coup ce que va
faire l'équipe de columbia pour pouvoir
généraliser un peu ces résultats c'est
qu'elle va refaire une enquête quatre
ans plus tard en 1944 auprès de 800
femmes pour étudier cette fois
spécifiquement la question des
procédures de choix on élargissant au
delà du vote à des questions comme le
choix d'un film la recommandation
d'objets de consommation ou la formation
des opinions sur une politique locale là
aussi cette enquête donnera lieu à un
livre publié en 1955 personal insurance
co écrit par paul lazarsfeld hesselink
cats c'est devenu un énorme classiques
des sciences sociales et il est très
souvent cité pour sa fameuse théorie du
tout est flou of communication à
laquelle on réfère souvent en français
dans simplement comme la théorie des
leaders d'opinion ou même parfois de
façon très littéral comme de la théorie
de la communication à double étage comme
semble le faire wikipédia ou même du
flux de communication à deux étages
comme semble le faire eric maigret dans
sa sociologie de la communication et des
médias
choisissez votre camp l'idée est en fait
assez simple c'est que les médias ne
parviennent pas à s'adresser directement
aux individus mais qu'ils sont filtrés
par des personnes influentes qu'on
appelle les leaders pignon je suis un
leader d'opinion en plus regarde j'ai un
cadre en bois qui montre que je suis
super bon marketing alors écoute moi
c'est pour ça qu'on parle des to study
of communications de la communication à
double étage parce que l' influence des
médias se fait en deux temps d'abord le
message est délivré par les médias à un
leader d'opinion qui est reconnu comme
compétent qui va ensuite filtrée
interpréter et convertir cette
information avant de la partager aux
personnes de son entourage par exemple
lorsqu'une personnalité politique
annonce à la télé qu'elle veut augmenter
les salaires en baissant les cotisations
sociales ça c'est une information
factuelle et cette information elle va
être filtrés et interprété par tonton
leaders d'opinion de droite qui va te
dire ah mais c'est super on va réduire
le coût du travail et gagner en
compétitivité ce qui nous permettra
d'augmenter les exportations et de
booster la balance commerciale et de
l'autre côté il ya tonton leaders
d'opinion de gauche qui te dire ah ben
là c'est de la connerie du sort la
baisse de cotisations ceux de
financement au moins pour les hôpitaux
et les retraites on est déjà
suffisamment dans la merde sans
supprimer encore des lits d'hôpitaux et
des postes d'infirmières oui parce que
c'est bien connu un letton de gauche ils
sont un peu vulgaire parfois et toi tu
devrais te forger un avis avec ça même
si dans ce cas précis la la probabilité
la plus forte c'est clairement que tu
t'en bat royalement les gonades parce
que leur affaire montre bien que 73 %
des personnes qui reçoivent beaucoup
d'injonction contradictoires se
désintéresse complètement de la campagne
électorale comme quoi cette croyance
populaire selon laquelle pour se forger
un avis informé il faudrait écouter tous
les camps politiques
tous les avis divergent en accordant une
attention égale à chacun bah on dirait
surtout une machine à fabriquer la basse
tension etonnant non
alors dans le livre de 55 personnel et
une fluence lazarsfeld étudier la
formation de toute sorte de jugement un
pas seulement des jugements politiques
et il montre bien que il n'existe pas du
beurre leaders d'opinion qui orienterait
les a dit de tout le monde surtout est
tout le temps en fait il ya plutôt des
leaders d'opinion ultra spécialisés dans
un domaine particulier pour lequel on
leur reconnaît une compétence par
exemple pour les sorties cinéma on
écoute plutôt les personnes les plus
âgées là où en matière de discussion sur
les affaires publiques locales c'est
plutôt le revenu et le niveau
d'éducation qui feront un leader
d'opinion crédible alors bien sûr ces
résultats ils ont très vite été
réutilisés par le marketing et la
communication
c'est notamment l'un des prismes qui
peut nous permettre de comprendre
l'émergence des influenceurs qui peuvent
jouer le rôle de leaders d'opinion grâce
au sentiment de proximité qu'ils
entretiennent avec leur audience c'est
tout le coût des relations parra social
tout ça tout ça je vous renvoie vers
tout plein de vidéos qui parle de ça et
c'est notamment ce qui explique que les
marques voulons faire la promotion de
leurs produits se sont peu à peu
désintéressés des superstars pour faire
des partenariats avec des influenceurs
jugé beaucoup plus proches de leur
public comme l'expliquent très bien un
créatif dans sa vidéo sur le sujet et
les marques commencent à remarquer que
l' influence de monsieur et madame tout
le monde qui a réussi à rassembler une
communauté sur internet connaît de
meilleurs résultats pour vendre produits
que de mettre une star dans une
publicité et quoi parce que
contrairement à une star hors de notre
réalité balle à vide un influenceur eh
ben elle est plus proche de celle des
consommateurs c'est plus réel à plus ou
moins le succès du marketing d'influencé
réside dans le fait que les marques
considère les prospects comme des
proches et plus comme des clients au
travers d influence et en plus le
contenu va tourner autour d'une
thématique précise s'adressait aux doses
précises pour laquelle la fluence heures
à une crédibilité dans son discours plus
ou moins bien utiliser le marketing
d'influencé offre de bien meilleurs
résultats pour beaucoup moins cher que
le celebrity marketing évidemment je
vous invite à voir toute cette vidéo qui
est vraiment très bien fait comme
d'habitude est d'ailleurs lui aussi
parle de la théorie de la communication
à double étage comme wikipedia il
propose la théorie de la communication à
double étage mais je sais pas si c'est
parce qu'il est belge c'est juste moi
qui trouve que ça sonne bizarrement mais
bref du coup la réponse de lazarsfeld à
la question de savoir si les campagnes
électorales influence les électeurs
semblent assez définitive non les médias
n'ont pas une influence directe car ils
sont filtrés par des leaders d'opinion
qui sont déjà très politisée et donc peu
enclins à changer d'avis et on voit
effectivement dans les résultats qu'une
très faible minorité de gens sont
susceptibles de changer d'avis au cours
d'une campagne bon ok mais c'est là que
j'ai envie de vous demander est ce que
l'absence de conversion des votes c'est
vraiment le signe d'une absence d'effets
de la campagne électorale
c'est un biais très connu en science
qu'on a tendance à davantage publier les
résultats qui montrent les effets
spectaculaires que les études qui
montrent une absence d'effet et en
sciences sociales on insiste bien plus
sur les éléments qui expliquent le
changement que sur les éléments qui
permettent d'expliquer la permanence de
l'ordre social pourtant cette
perpétuation elle est bien loin d'être
mécanique ou naturels et elles méritent
souvent d'être expliquée comme le
montrera le sociologue todd gitlin dans
un article de 1978 et peut être
paradoxal de parler d'un effet limité
des médias quand on parle en fait d'
influence qui vont dans le sens d'un
statu quo de fait qui souligne que le
principal résultat des campagnes
électorales semble précisément le
renforcement des convictions
préexistantes une campagne c'est certain
moment pour sensibiliser et convaincre
mais c'est surtout un moment pour
mobiliser et réactiver des loyautés déjà
existantes
c'est quelque chose qu'on a notamment vu
lors de cette dernière campagne
électorale à gauche l'essentiel n'était
pas vraiment de convaincre les électeurs
indécis et difficilement accessible
mais plutôt au contraire de rassembler
et de mobiliser au sein de son propre
camp pour incarner le vote utile le vote
utile ça ça n'a jamais été notre
argument donc moi je vais pas l'utiliser
mais ce que je peux dire c'est que si
vous votez pour moi c'est le vote le
plus concret pas seulement pour un
programme mais pour éliminer l'extrême
droite dès le premier tour
ce qui se passe c'est que les messages
partisans fournissent aux plus
convaincus et au plus politisé un stock
d'arguments qui confortent leurs
convictions ils vont ensuite relais
décoder et les filtrer avant de les
répercuter auprès des membres de leurs
groupes primaires d'appartenance
du coup pour les électeurs les moins
politisées la campagne déclenché un
processus d'activation des
prédispositions sociales à voter pour
tel ou tel parti par le biais des
leaders d'opinion qui votent selon leur
conscience nous on n'est pas là pour les
influencer puis secret du vote de toute
façon secret du vote nous on dire
en fait on retient souvent le mécanisme
du tout steve kloves communication dans
les ouvrages de lazarsfeld mais le plus
intéressant c'est peut-être le phénomène
d'appropriation sélective des messages
contrairement à ce que pensent et
l'école de francfort on voit que les
électeurs oppose aux médias des formes
variées de résistance
globalement si le candidat qu'on
soutient dit une chose avec laquelle on
est en désaccord on aura souvent
tendance à refouler cette information
voire carrément à l'oublier ou à
l'ignorer et c'est vrai qu'on remarque
parfois avec amusement que les partisans
politiques peuvent souvent faire preuve
d'une certaine mauvaise foi dans la
défense de leur candidat
tout ce qu'on a demandé on l'a eu non il
n'y a rien à reprocher la fraude fiscale
c'est pas un vol ou c'est d'argent
public d'une certaine manière et du
moment que je suis sur mac rompt pas peu
importe mais de fausses fiscale mais ça
concerne lui ça concerne pas les autres
c'est personnel ça c'est personnel ça ça
n'intéresse personne ça ça n'intéresse
pas la population ça ne nous regarde pas
sa vie privée c est ce que je regarde
c'est la ville comment il entretient la
ville du coup faites quand même
attention avant d'adhérer à la théorie
du zéro et fait 1 ce n'est pas parce que
vous n'avez pas changé d'avis que la
campagne médiatique ne vous a pas
influencer on pourrait même défendre le
fait que c'est précisément la marque de
son efficacité le meeting c'est un
moment d'ivresse collective en se
réchauffant entre nous on s'emporte le
public le candidat est une forme
d'abandon on laisse son esprit critique
de côté on applaudit on hurle jean-luc
je ne crie pas mon nom
hydroliennes cet épisode de sociaux
classiques est maintenant terminée je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi c'est
toujours un peu frustrant de s'arrêter
là on pourrait bien sûr toujours avoir
plus de choses à dire on pourra parler
de travaux un peu plus récents au
prochain épisode en attendant j'espère
que ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à mettre
un pouce vers le haut à vous abonner si
c'est pas déjà fait vous pouvez me
laisser un petit commentaire est en tout
cas ne partez pas trop loin parce qu'il
ya plein de nouveaux projets qui vont
arriver sur la chaîne prochainement je
vous en parlerai plus tard n'oubliez pas
que le livre est toujours disponible en
librairie si vous êtes a envie de mieux
comprendre le monde avec des exemples
issus de la pop culture moi je vous fais
des gros bizot a très vite ciao
[Musique]